[Music]
and this game I'm about to show you is a
game that was played in 1983 and are you
doing in Lugano Switzerland okay just a
second let me to make sure I can do this
yeah cool okay and my opponent is the
renowned author chess grandmaster John
none have you heard of John none he's
written numerous books and he's a
remarkable remarkable person in the
clarity of his thought like if you read
his his works he's directly on target
like a hundred percent of the time he's
directly on target and he speaks
succinctly to the points that he's
trying to make in this game that I
played was what you might call a
Donnybrook I mean it was just wild like
everything's going on in a really really
crazy game and you know I was confused
by all the things and all the
combinations and all the possibilities
that was going on in the game and after
the game we have what we call in chess
'post mortem you know after death like
we sit down with each other we discuss
well maybe I should have done this and
maybe I should have done that and blah
blah blah so I was explaining to him
that well you know here there's a very
attractive young lady that walked by and
I got distracted
and I was analyzing properly and he was
like nodding his head and thoughtful
understanding and then when I finished
he said I don't know what you're talking
about so I said well you know you get
distracted you start thinking about
dinner or what you're going to have for
lunch or this or that and other thoughts
come through your head during the game
and he said
what I said John just a fake John John
John you know you're at the board you're
concentrating you're trying to analyze
but for some reason your mind's just not
working and you know other thoughts
distract you and he goes really like I
go yeah yeah yeah this happens to
everybody it happens to you and he goes
no well this is like one of those
doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo moments like
wow when this guy is focused he's so
focused a little history about John
Donne he graduated from the University
of Oxford the youngest graduate doctor
in mathematics since like cardinal rules
li 1674 or something like that
and he is absolutely a mathematical
genius just off the charts something
very very special about him and his
discipline and concentration at the
board was just amazing whereas I was all
over the map now before I get started
how many of you play E for it's learned
and how many display caro-kann 1 2 3
there you go
well I as I was mentioning I was black
this game was played in Lugano in 1983
just a beautiful beautiful the italian
canton of switzerland just a beautiful
location and it was a major major swiss
tournament in those years and an
extremely top-heavy tournament with
really powerful grandmasters and John
Mutt was one of the favorites I'm
tasting him with black and in a Swiss
tournament having the white pieces is
considered a real advantage and I played
the caro-kann he played d4 and in Swiss
tournaments
really you got a play for the win and
today against the car con 'if I've what
is called the advance caro-kann is
considered one of the most promising
lines for
white and it's what modern players do to
gain the advantage well in a sense it's
almost a little bit like the French
defense I haven't yet committed my pawn
to e6 which means that I should first
take advantage of this opportunity to
bring my to develop my bishop outside of
my pawn chain and that's what I did
that's like Bishop f5 and in those days
oops that's not what I wanted yes yes
sir besides so it is in fact the
standard move yes which is yes that's is
just to go back what Rex is asking is in
this position Bobby Fischer is white
very often played captures on d5
captures on d5 and Bishop d3 this is
considered a very very solid alternative
for black before white pardon me as it's
kind of like a Queens gambit declined
with colors reverse and White has an
extra tempo so the idea is that after
Knight C 6 C 3 we get a kind of what is
called a calls bad structure of a Queens
gambit declined for white it's a funny
story
Bobby liked this line so much that he
played it in the candidates tournament
in bled and there was a couple of
Soviets at Rosia and Cara's Hall so
forth and so on and and and when the
Soviets all realized that that Bobby was
playing this variation and they didn't
think it was challenging enough for
white there was like a lineup of Soviet
players on the plate of blacks lack of
this position against Bobby it's
considered slight smidgen of an
advantage for white we go back ok and we
get the advanced and Bishop f5 Knight c3
okay so everything standard I played e7
e6 okay so in a sense what I want to do
with black is I mean white obviously has
a very nice wedge of pawns in the center
and I want to play the move c6 c5 knight
c6 and put pressure against the d4 d5
pawns from white point of view and we
can see it now most especially with the
next white move is white wants to take
advantage of this bishop on f5 and he
played the move G for attacking my
bishop my bishop went to g6 and let me
just make sure that I have the right of
move order here yes okay so he now
played Knight G - E - and what white is
what white is intending is to take
advantage of this bishop he wants to
play Knight f4 and h4 and h5 trapping
the bishop you white would especially
like to play Knight f4 and capturing
this bishop when H takes g6 isn't
available so he wants to play h4 provoke
a move like h6 Knight f4 and take that
bishop okay after night GE - I played c5
so following up with my intention of
course which is the blow up white in the
center white played h4 I played h6 now
let me make sure it's Bishop e3 okay
okay I played h6 he played Bishop e3 I
played knight c6 you play Queen d2
I play Queen b6 he played h5 I played
Bishop h7 and he castled okay so in a
sense the battle lines are being drawn
and wherever you look in the position
white is really ready to pounce on
blacks game so if it was white turn to
play White's intention is to play f2 to
f4 f4 f5 with two purposes the first of
which is once White's pawn gets to fi
this diagonal of this Bishop is closed
secondly once this pawn gets to f5
this Knight could come up behind it
Knight f4 and pressure the e6 and the d5
pawns now furthermore white is really
hoping that I would capture on d4
because then if you look at from the if
you look at the position from the point
of view of development it's very clear
that white has a significant lead in
development first of all he's
threatening Knight takes c6 with a
discovery against the Queen on b6 if I
play the move Bishop c5 to stop the
discovery gets the Queen
there is Knight a for winning a piece my
queen is a target and once again f4 is
coming up and blacks in deep deep
trouble
so whoops castles so in this position
it's sort of like man I can't blow up
the center if I try to develop my knight
for example Knight isse Evan well in the
first place white could capture this
pawn with the tempo followed up with f4
White's it's got a great position I
can't capture
I can't move if I Castle all kinds of
bad things are happening and finally I
also have to pay attention to this move
Knight
for attacking my queen on v6 and my pawn
on c5 so by all rights white is doing
just great and I played the move c4 okay
so yes sir
precisely I I mean I literally I had no
other option
yeah yeah exactly everything else was in
period no matter where I met him on
whatever part of the board I was going
to be in trouble so I played c4 oh yes
oh yes definitely exactly that kind of
thing actually was closer to 20 and here
you know this was a novelty at the time
in fact blacks whole strategy up until
this game had been played black hole
strategy was considered simply bad for
the second player that is to say blacks
results in this position had been awful
and the move c4 was quite a surprise for
my opponent so let me just go ahead so
okay what can we make of this position
on the first hand it it appears that
white has superior development superior
space the safe King on the other hand
there's a niggling there's a niggling
something I mean there is a possibility
that night before which in combination
with the bishop on h7 will capture this
pawn on c2 and so the so John had no no
compunctions no problems playing the
move f4 which looks really great right I
mean because it's definitely clear that
White's intention is to play f5 closing
that Bishop followed up with night
for heck there might even be a peace
sacrifice against that pawn on d5 there
could be a Bishop g2 kind of thing so it
really looks like black Cindy trouble
right is there any disagreement about
this I mean I hate to talk down my own
game but if the reality is all my pieces
are still undeveloped okay and I played
the move Queen a five can somebody tell
me why I played the move Queen a five
okay there is a pin that's true I mean
it's not something that's very severe in
the sense that if I brought the bishop
here well he may try to block it with a
three but there was another reason okay
that's a good point you know also to
stop his knight from potentially moving
to a 4 and C 5 Julian on the button on
the button so undeveloped behind in
space Kings still in the center I'm
going on the attack just as Julian says
my intention is to release the B pond
I want to go B 5 B 4 attack his knight
and when the knight moves I don't care
where I want to come down here and
capture the pawn on a - okay so now the
battle is joined he plays f5 and I play
b5 okay whoa what is going on well in
the first place
obviously my intention is to play b4 and
it would probably be a very big mistake
for him to play a 2 a 3 in the first
place he's kind of tempting me with
Bishop takes a 3 sacrificing a bishop
to pond but in the second case after a
3b for anyway eight eggs before I can
get in a queen a one check let me just
put that on the board pardon me I'll put
this on the board so in case he plays a
three I could come down and I would be
pretty threatening like for example
after moved like Knight takes because my
threat in the position is Knight a to
check and mate okay he could defend that
threat but literally I've made good
inroads against his King for example we
can just continue the line once more
Knight c3 rook b8 and we can see that my
threat is to play Knight a to check
Knight takes a - Queen takes B to mate
so I'm getting there very fast so we're
not going to play a 3/4 white oops we're
not going to play a 3/4 light my
opponent so around this part you know
like ok I was like really getting
excited about my attack I thought that I
were going to go b4 and capture his
Knight and I may win a piece but I I'm
so far behind he's got some some
compensation for sure my opponent
shocked me with a very strong move
Knight takes d5 woah woah woah that was
a real a real shock well the first place
he took a pawn I don't like that when my
ponies take bond in the second place
potentially he is opening up this
diagonal for his bishop if I were to
take this night I would get killed I
could see I could get killed here it
takes for example takes Knight takes
bishop here let's say he
fens I defend pardon me rook here night
here it's very clear why it's going to
get a second pawn in this bishop well
that's the kind of issue into right okay
so that Bishop would be in tomb so this
is a position I really really want to
avoid let's go back for a second let's
imagine that black plays Queen takes D
to check rook takes D to pawn takes d5
let's imagine Bishop to g2 let's imagine
rook to d8 now here Knight c3 could very
well run into bishop before unlike the
previous variation now the knight is
pinned so white can take a different
approach
he can play Knight here and again this
was a position I really didn't want to
have anything to do with because I just
thought you know okay White's got a good
chance of winning a second pond and I
just didn't see how this Bishop was ever
going to get back into the game so I
didn't want to trade Queens exactly
so my next uh the next question I had is
what about my playing hoops excuse me
what about my playing Queen takes a two
okay so here I had a real think about
the position I thought that he would
play knight on d5 attacks my queen I
would give him a check he would go back
with a knight now what I saw in my
mind's eye and what I was very fearful
about
was that the bishop would come to g2
which would be on this really nice
diagonal this Knight was going to come
to c3 pressure this pawn and the one I
was most fearful for was that there
might be an opportunity for him to play
d5 as my king is stuck in the center of
the board so I was very happy in this
position to play a different move
where's my mouse there it is by b5
before when all the alternatives aren't
working you got to come up with
something a little bit more inventive
so I played b5 before pardon me well
that will that was that kind of a queen
swap variation where I was afraid he
would win a second pawn so now I was
like kind of happy because in my mind's
eye if this knight retreats I will play
c4 c3 and Queen takes a two and his King
his King is getting blown up so so now
at this point you know like the pressure
really keeps going up ratcheting up he's
sacrificing I'm refusing his sacrifices
[Music]
he can't bring his knight back because
of the move I said c3 and Queen takes a
two he played Knight c7 check knight c7
check now I of course captured his
Knight and now he played Knight f4
okay I beg your pardon this is an
excellent he as we saw he played 97
check this is an excellent opportunity
to ask what else should white play I'm
also keeping in mind I'm threatening to
play Queen takes a two and check and
mate so he really needs to be able to
defend that threat with a knight on b1
so what else could white play other than
97 exactly and 97 was to to get my Queen
out of there and while I'm being
distracted he's going to make his own
threats well he's about you're about to
see some Knights e7 check Queen takes
Knight f4 well and now we can see what
White has in mind although he sacrificed
a piece it's very clear that if he could
play Bishop takes e4 that Bishop would
act as a great defender and the king
also this pawn on e6 is really coming
under fire like you know Here I am I'm a
piece up but I don't know what's going
on any questions I am in yes please
okay a very very fair question indeed so
imagine King B wanted to stop me from
going to a - well in those previous
positions we had been looking at we had
actually traded Queens right and there
had been a possibility for him of
playing Knight c3 in winning a second
pawn with Queens on the board
this idea of Knight f4 Bishop g2 is not
working because first of all I've got an
extra
fender and secondly the moment this
night moves I get to play see three and
my queen on a five protects x-rays the
defense of the c3 square so having the
extra having the Queen's on the board
really benefits me he doesn't get any
compensation from the sacrifice piece
Rex what if I yes what if I played my
precisely
okay so ninety seven check the question
that Rex has and it's a darn good
question
adds that Rex you took the words right
out of my mouth black says please please
please please take my rook because then
when you take my rook then Queen takes a
two it's Kapow the problem is he doesn't
take the rook the problem is he plays
the move d5 like and my king is sitting
on an open highway be like in the middle
of the road and there is no protection
so like if we played one or two more
moves we can really see this in like
living color
after takes takes the threat of course
is to go Queen to d7 check and mate on
the next turn that's going to hurt very
hurt big-time
oh not at all okay so Queen takes c7
Knight f4 and now again if he White's a
piece down for a pawn okay I should be
so happy right I mean but look it's
what's happening if he manages to play
Bishop takes c4 and win a second pawn
that bishop on c4 will be a fantastic
defender I mean the bishop could drop
back and protect the King but even worse
it's positioned the bishops going to be
a horrible monster on this diagonal so I
didn't want him taking my pawn so I
pushed it in three now he didn't want to
take the pond and expose his King
because after it takes takes Queen takes
I'll play Bishop before and his King
position is really getting wide open so
he played queen G - and have you done
this in your games it's like you invite
your opponent to put a pond in front of
the king and then the enemy uses your
own pond as a defender well that was the
idea here
Queen G - pawn takes check King b1 the
idea is he doesn't want to take this
pond he wants this pawn to I mean is it
a black pawn or a white pond right I
mean yeah it's so but King takes could
potentially expose the king to a queen
c3 check in the near future so Queen
takes here here now okay
[Music]
I played night on g8 to e7 you got it
yes Julian
well yes okay that's a very good
question the problem for me is that if I
capture this pawn on f5 let's ask the
class if you are white how would you
want to follow up White's position
keeping in mind you played queen g2 for
a reason right to put pressure on this
well what Julian is saying is that
capturing does open up the file
but then after Bishop takes that bishop
comes back into the game White has a way
of winning a piece back in this position
indeed Bishop b5 with a threat of
capturing the knight on c6 and whether
you play 97 or rook c8 d phi is a
consequence of that and it's a light
note Oh timeout that's not what I'm
agreeing to so let's see what happened
Knight ge7 he played Bishop c4 now again
the idea this move is kind of
multi-purpose first of all you know like
the King does like defenders I mean
let's face it so the bishop could come
back here to protect but even more he's
targeting this pawn on e6 so could
anybody please guess what I played
Knight takes f5 okay I could give back
the piece G takes Bishop takes f5 then
maybe Bishop b5 and d5 just to be clear
what Julian has whoops escape what
Julian has you suggested that perhaps I
should be generous and return the piece
and we get some position like this where
Kapow
once again my under achieving
development is going to is going to hurt
the positions blowing up in my King is
still in the center and as Michael
pointed out that Queen on g2 means that
you're not going to move your bishop
because you'll lose the pawn and my
Kings the target yep
okay so I need some help here guys
suggestions pardon me okay g5 that runs
into what Michael just said I'm tacking
with the H pond there's an opposite and
bang if I have to take the knight takes
a 6 so that's splat and you know it's
all absolutely all the way yeah nice
yeah Knight c3 g4 h4 h5 he's been in it
I mean he's he's God has you know he's
put to the foot foot to the gas pedal
here he's not stopping for nothing well
my King's under attack don't you think
it's a good idea to get out of it yeah
my King's under attack let's get out of
Dodge
okay so his turn so you all agree that
he should capture this pawn on e6 right
and I move my king a little bit further
and now he captured this pawn on f7 whoa
is this wild or what IV you know like my
god you know my roof is caving in if
it's his turn he's ready for ninety six
he's got these past pawns in the center
of the board and he's coming and my god
and I won't say it but you know in
the time truck it was not time trouble
yet but the clock's ticking right I mean
you can really feel that the tension
building okay
like wild yeah that in fact that was
exactly my move Knight to a5 like I'm
not worried about Knight to e6 because
that Bishop is hanging okay Knight to e6
attacks the Queen and the rook and oh I
forgot me I'm the worst coach in the
world I've tailed us to all the kids who
come in the door like I'm a bad coach
when when white captured this pawn and
captured this pawn not only did he get a
pawn to the seventh and he won two pawns
but what happened for blacks benefit how
did black benefit from the loss of these
two pawns
that's my lurking ICBM right there you
know it's in a silo but baby it is
working and at the end of the rainbow
there is a king so if he goes ninety six
let's see how this would work out my
intention if I remember was to play
Queen takes and if he takes my rook now
fortunately uh is not that important he
is not threatening Queen d7 mate because
I do have it covered my intention was to
go Knight here threatening Knight check
here so that in case of Bishop here
Queen take c2 and check and mate
well so that was why he couldn't jump
with his Knight to e6 instead oh here
was another key moment my opponent
played Bishop to d3 okay
could somebody tell me how I would have
responded had he played Bishop to b3
Julian got an idea okay in fact you are
absolutely correct my young buck eight
takes beef and now Rex is right on it
boy talk about johnny-on-the-spot clean
a five now remember what I was saying
about this pawn is kind of be offering
white some should King some shelter
obviously in this particular case I'm
forcing its capture
so after King takes how does black
continue correct and what was I saying
about my bishop take the pawn with check
its pin and guess what is falling
this guy's falling as well so it's a
complete collapse for white so that was
why John didn't play Bishop b3 he played
Bishop to d3 Bishop to d3 so he wants to
neutralize my yes sir yeah well I don't
know if he was playing poorly at the
time well yeah but don't forget he's
still got these connected pawns and when
he went into this variation keep in mind
that at the time of the theory that move
C 5 c4 was unknown and the black players
just dismissed this line is simply
bad for black so he was going he was
going into a line which he thought
according to the theory books at the
time was greatly in his advantage and
suddenly he's being thrown back by this
very strange-looking attack I'm
attacking without any develop
development okay after Bishop d3 what
did I play what are my choices what are
my choice if I play Bishop tags d3 well
there's a lot of ways he could recapture
I think the simplest one is with the
rook and I still gotta face the music of
knight c6 I need a good move I need a
good move yes yes thank you very much
Knight c4 so in the first place this not
only attacks his Bishop on e3 but it
sets up the possibility of night a3
check King takes b2 Queen c3 check and
I'm getting dangerously close to his
king
so after Knight c4 he was compelled to
capture on c4 Bishop takes c4 Queen
takes c4 and now he saw that there are
lots of issues he's facing including a
move like rook c8 putting pressure on c2
he plays the move rook h2 to defend
whoops to defend the pawn on c2 I played
Knight d5 Knight takes d5 rook takes d5
d6 whose odds are getting those bonds
are hitting closer and closer I felt
like what is that space invaders you
know don't
the guy's coming closer he's also ready
to go Bishop f4 check I don't know my
king isn't isn't a little bit of a
trouble but hey I've got I've got this
guy this guy is my you know secret
weapon that Bishop on h7 that was really
feeling good about that
still yes exactly right
okay so rook a5 going after that pawn on
a - unfortunately runs into a small
smidgen of a problem I checked with the
bishop the King moves and then run and I
got a signed score sheets hate that hate
that okay so what did I do
it's a toughy it's a toughy Bishop d6 is
a very very reasonable move because it
attacks the rook my problem with Bishop
d6 is he's going to go Queen e2 and if I
trade Queens I'm worried that these two
pawns are going to cause an accident
with me on the wrong side of the
accident I gotta be fast I gotta be fast
yes this Queen where Hartley thanks for
which which problem with this well he
will take and and then he will take this
pawn with his king darn it
see in d3 with upon because the problem
is is I really want to get that pawn off
the board in fact that pawn is really
helping white tremendously so I play d3
so he captured my pawn
I mean this is such a tricky game I have
to shoot okay beautiful move nice move
on the button Queen a6 I mean isn't this
a very strange game like my pieces I
mean you know I haven't developed my
pieces and yet I've been on attack and
so is he I mean we've been who's doing
what to whom he doesn't have time to
capture my rook thanks to the threat of
Queen a1 check and mate and in fact this
threat of Queen a1 mate is so powerful
he is obligated to capture the pawn King
takes B - ok what's the material count
one two three four five six seven one
two three four pawns for the bishop oh I
apologize I did it wrong he didn't play
after Queen a6 he first gave me a check
with his bishop I apologize I move my
king and then he captured this pawn so
just the inclusion of that Bishop check
okay
now let's go get him how did I do it
Queen a3 check of course now he can't
move back with this king i king b1
keeping in mind my Bishop Queen takes b3
is with a check so I played on me he
played the only move King c3
okay first I have to confess just to
gain a little time I first played Queen
check King here Queen check I repeated
the position just to gain a full time on
the clock King here and what was the
suggestion this should be for check okay
King see for what now don't don't forget
one thing one thing you got to keep in
mind please don't lock Queen a check and
make that would be like Oh Queen a5 if I
take the rook Julian it's okay but it is
my rook by just sacrificed
isn't it funny I was looking at this
position I was looking this position and
man I couldn't make things work for me
one trick that Queen comes over I mean I
was looking at Queen a5 Queen takes d5
man I just thought that you know there
had to be something I mean his Kings
right up there right up in front of the
board right by me well quick he takes
the rook he takes the rook
no okay the problem with the other rook
to d8 what was the problem yeah there
was a problem there was a problem I
think it was a pawn push okay this is a
tricky move I apologize in advance I
tell you what I did I played Bishop e7
threatening yes Julian
I'm sorry at what moment Queen a6 check
the price yeah this is a nice one it's
really nice if I go queen a6 check and
the idea is if he takes the rook to go
Queen here and take ok you can play King
takes King takes rook the b5 check he
comes back with the King I mean he's
like a slippery devil you know like a
quarterback scrambling you know so King
takes here this is what I was fearful
from and again I just didn't see the
chat Nate and his Kings out there
free-floating but nope so what I did is
I played Bishop e7 now I'm threatening
Madon Madon 3 I think or something like
that my threat is to go Queen Shaq King
takes rook d8 check and if king c6 Queen
here mate okay so Queen before check is
my threat he came back with the King and
remember a moment ago my bishop was on
f8 so I hike 1 that tempo my Bishop is
now on e7 but I so what do I do now
exactly why didn't the Queen take the
rook okay
you only get one answer and it is creepy
for me
and the answer is Bishop e7 he went King
c3 and now okay so I improved my
position I got my bishop from here to
here I got the extra move for what it's
worth I don't know what it's worth but
here again I had to rethink of how am I
going to get his King this was a toughy
I tell you and by the way I was really
worried that if I didn't get his King
those ponds were going to eventually
cost me the game should I take a
repetition Oh
Bravo Michael Queen a5 check King has to
go to be to no choice okay now what
queen a3 check he goes back to c3 that's
just a repetition so we can rule out
Queen a3 yeah
Bishop a3 check now we got it going now
he cannot go King to a2 because that
would allow me bishop before check and
Bishop c3 with unstoppable made on a1 he
had to drop back with his King King b1
and now correctamundo threatening mate
Queen c3 Bishop c1 he has to defend and
I did what
okay Queen takes us but I don't you know
it's the weirdest thing I think I didn't
do that I didn't do that
I mean it's begging it's begging now I
queen take cb3 check I think he would he
has to move his king and then don't
forget his queen and rook the fancy too
so Queen take C - I think Queen takes b3
check had to be a great move had to be
winning move my flag I mean I still had
a minute or so but I saw what I thought
was simple so I did something else
beside Queen takes b3 what else is there
good correctamundo Bishop takes c1 now
he can't take with the rook because
Queen takes b3 King a1 rook on d5 to a5
with a check he's got to stop Queen
takes Queen B to mate so he took my
bishop now what did I do
right on
Queen a1 check King D - what do i do you
Julian okay how many of you like look
takes d4 check wait her ex wasn't ready
to raise his hand now keep in mind I had
this visceral fear that I was going to
allow a queen h8 check at some moment so
I wanted to keep that rook on d5 for as
long as I possibly could Green takes d4
check and hear my opponent stop the
clock if I if he goes King a1 that is a
checkmate
so he would have to choose either e 2 or
e 1 and then I capture the rook with
check and my attack would continue was
that a wild game or what right I mean
you know you just don't know what's
going on sometimes within these Grand
Master games and really this was a
confusing post-mortem because if we just
go back to more or less the opening when
to the girl Robin
well I mean you know it was one of those
things that we get a position like this
out of the opening John has played all
of the approved moves you know when he
played this move Knight takes d5 going
into the sacrificial variations
he had calculated outcomes that were
very favorable for him and after all
from the point of view of development
and King safety and all of the rest you
really think that White's on top at this
point and after b4 check takes here here
it really it has the feeling that you
know white has great compensation for
his piece just simply brilliant and in a
couple more moves there's going to be
this avalanche of ponds that are going
to win back material and the King
actually looks safe but it didn't so one
of the things that John was asking me is
like the old proverbial where did I go
wrong where did I go wrong
chess is a mystery I'm not sure well I
thank you all for coming this evening I
did I did and the computer today's
modern day computer if you look at this
position after yet this this this this
they they saw that they like whites
position they like whites position they
like whites position and then it goes
down like it just it goes off a cliff
so here I'll tell you where John went
wrong and it was right here right here
in this position right here in this
position remember when he played that
move h5 let's take it back for a moment
let's imagine that John had played
castles instead now let's imagine I try
to get into the same variations as the
game which was c4 and now we can imagine
f4 and let's say I played the move Queen
a five and now here's all the difference
in the world
the pawn comes to f5 with a gain of time
when he played that move h5 kicking me
back he was putting me actually onto a
safer
we're yeah now if I capture on f5 now
the difference is clear to behold that
after night f4
well this guy is falling maybe this guy
will fall next I have to be a little bit
Larry that he's going to take the bishop
one moment and that one little move that
one little move h5 made it all possible
[Music]